I hate brushing my teeth it's another
chore I want to get done as fast as
humanly possible I know it's terrible
dental hygiene but over the last week
I've cleaned up my act or at least my
teeth with a new Bluetooth toothbrush
I didn't say blue teeth I said blue
tooth this is oral Bea's smart series
electric toothbrush it pairs with your
iPhone or your Android phone to coach
you through your brushing regimen and
gives you feedback on your brushing
habits I know do we really need this
what's next
blue tooth toilet paper but for a gadget
lover like me it's been really helpful
I've been spending way more time in here
brushing my teeth that's the main goal
to get you brushing for the dentist
recommended 2 minutes as soon as you
pair the phone and the brush and begin
brushing the clock starts prompting you
to move to another quadrant of your
mouth every 30 seconds you can also
customize the Tyler with a mouth when
you're out see what area you should be
focusing on the app and the brush will
alert you if you're brushing too hard
but you can also extend the brushing
session and program in some more focused
care adding a few extra seconds to a
specific area
oral-b suggests working with your
dentist on this so I called up my
dentist the best place to focus is on
the lingual side that's inside of yellow
enternity
yellow a grunty and continue to floss
every day sorry
no Bluetooth floss yet she was happy to
hear that when you're all done it
prompts you to clean your tongue with a
brush and then floss then you get a
summary of your entire session and a
smiley face but my favorite part of the
app is that it distracts you during the
2 minute brushing process with news
headlines your calendar weather brushing
tips and inspirational quotes trust
yourself then you will know how
to live things I always wanted to know
while brushing my teeth unfortunately in
the app you can't customize it with your
own social media feeds or other news
sources but I do wish there was a place
in the app to see if it was connected to
the brush and to see the remaining
battery life the package should also
include some sort of screen protector
for your phone toothpaste is not a
recommended screen cleaner the smart
series is on sale now in Europe and will
be available in the US this fall for
$159 there will be two other cheaper
blue toothbrushes coming out later this
year look how clean these teeth are sure
there are still lots of other things I'd
rather be doing for two minutes than
brushing my teeth but putting bluetooth
in a toothbrush and the phone in my hand
has certainly encouraged me to brush
longer and better now only if I could
give up these blue lollipops